Transcriber: HİBA HIJAZI ŞEHAB
Gözden geçirme: Ilayda Gokgoz
Çukurova Üniversitesi Tıp Fakültesi
Çocuk Sağlığı ve Hastalıkları
Anabilim Dalı Öğretim Üyesiyim.
Sizlere tüm hayatımızı etkileyen
yaşamın ilk dönemini,
gebeliğin ilk gününden itibaren olan
bu en kritik en hassas dönemi,
bunun önemini vurgulamak için kullanılan
ve bir kısmımız bu bilgiyi ilk günkü
kavramını kullanarak anlatmaya ve
bu dönemi etkileyen faktörleri
sunmaya çalışacağım.
Biliyorsunuz ülkelerin gelişmişlik düzeyi
aslında bebek ölüm hızları ile belirlenir.
Ne kadar az ölüyorsa çocuklar,
o ülke o kadar gelişmiş demektir.
140 milyon bebek doğuyor ve bunların
maalesef her yıl doğan bebeklerin ölümü,
ilk baktığımız zaman
ilk dönemlerde daha çok oluyor.
Yani ilk 5 yıl ölümlerine baktığımız
zamanda daha çok ilk 2 yaşta onunda
en fazla ilk 1 ayda
ve ilk günlerde oluyor.
Dolayısıyla ilk günler çok önemli.
yaşama bu ilk dönemlerde tutulmaya
baktığımız zaman ülkelerin gelişmişliğini
buradaki bizim ülkemizde de görüyorsunuz.
Yaklaşık olarak bebeklerin.
İlk yılı ilk binde 9'u kaybediliyor.
Bizim ülkemizde binde 14 de ilk 5.5
ay içerisinde kaybediliyor.
Şimdi bu dönem yaşama tutunmak
da bu kadar.
Önemli olan bu dönemi.
Gelişmeye baktığımız zaman, büyümeye
baktığımız zaman gerek boy olsun, gerek
kilo olsun, gerek baş çevresi olsun bu
dönemin yine en kritik olduğunu görüyoruz.
Çünkü beyin hücreleri ehh ek.
En çok bu dönemde beyin gelişmekte.
Doğduğu zaman bir bebek, doğduğu zaman en
fazla hücre bu dönemde sahip olmakta.
Bağlantı çok önemli.
Beyin hücreleri arasında bu bağlantı
en çok bu dönemde olmakta ve artık.
2 yaşına geldiğimiz zaman beyin
gelişiminin yüzde sekseni tamamlanmakta,
ve beyin ağırlığı 3 katına çıkmakta.
Bunu, takip ettiğimiz bebeklerde
gelişme baktığımız zaman
konuşma olsun
diye gelişim olsun, yürüme olsun,
gelişim de bunu görüyoruz.
Yani bakım ilk 2 yıl en önemli,
en kritik dönem.
Peki o zaman bu ilk iki
yılı koyduğumuz zaman.
Ama yaşamın başladığı daha ilk nedenin ilk
günden itibaren o 9 ayı eklediğimiz
zaman bir bin gün ortaya çıkıyor.
İşte bu bin gün.
Bütün yaşamı etkileyen bir dönem.
Bu dönemle ilgili olarak
da acaba bu genetik.
Faktörler dışında epigenetik faktörler
dışında ne etkiliyor?
Bu dönemi acaba çevresel
olarak etkileniyor mu?
Bu dönemden itibaren bir
program var mı acaba?
Bununla ilgili olarak aslında 1960 yılında
yapılan bir hayvan deneyi.
Bunun ilk işaretlerini veren
bir çalışmaydı .
Bu çalışmada erken dönemde beslenme
eksikliği olan farelere daha sonra fazla
gıda verilmesinin bile onun vücut yapısını
ve ilgili olumsuzlukları
değiştirmediği, aksine daha kötü sonuçlara
gittiği, bununla ilgili olarak ta
1975 yılında yapılan çalışmada
bunu ilk olarak erken dönemdeki
bu faktörlerin
ileri dönemde yaşamın ileri döneme
etkilerinin olduğu gösteren
bu çalışma idi.
Ancak bu çok bilinmeyen çalışmadan
yıllar sonra
1986 yılında yayınlanan çalışmada
Barker isminde virüsün İngiltere'deki
o yirminci yüzyılda.
Kalp hastalıklarının çok
olduğu bir coğrafyada.
Onların doğumuna baktığı zaman, onların
bir çoğunun o dönemde çocukların öldüğünü
yaşayanların da düşük doğum ağırlıklı
olduğunu görünce bununla bir ilişki
olabileceğini ben 1975 deki çalışma gibi
düşünerek yeni ve geriye dönük
bu kayıtlardan bunu toplayınca
bir hipotez ileri sürüyor.
Buna Barker hipotezi dediğimiz bu hipotez.
Anne karnındaki gelişimi duyarlı olduğu,
bir dönemdeki uyarıların kalıcı ve uzun
dönemde etkilere yol açtığı ve bunun da
artık bir programlama mesajı istemek
cenin demek olarak ifade etmiş .
Ya da kısaca biz erken dönemde
programlama diyebiliriz.
Yani bebeğin yapısını sadece genetik
faktörler belirlemiyor.
Bunun üzerine anne karnında ilk rahmine
düştüğü andan itibaren birçok faktörler
etki ediyor.
Mesela hormonlar etki ediyor.
En çok bilinen kortizon.
Büyümeyi durduran işlemlerin stresi olduğu
zaman salgılanan kortizol olumsuz
etki ediyor.
Kötü beslenme gene strese neden oluyor.
O da gene olumsuz etki ediyor.
mesela
Protein gebelik döneminde annenin kendi
ihtiyacı var ama onun üzerine en az
alması gereken bir 42 gram olması lazım.
Bakın gelişmiş ülkelerde 92 gram alıyor.
Ama işte geri kalmış ülkelerde
6 gram alıyor.
protein düşük almak çok olumsuz
sonuçlara neden oluyor.
Mesela düşük protein alındığı zaman bu
çocukların ileriki dönemde kan basıncı
tansiyonu yüksek oluyor.
Ya da annenin gebelik boyunca kilosu az
ise kan basıncında artış , koroner kalp
hastalığı fazla oluyor ya da gebelikte
yüksek bir yağlı diyetle beslenme.
Aşırı kilo da bebeğin erişkin zamanda
kardiyovasküler hastalıklara neden oluyor.
Sadece bu ana temel gıdalar değil,
vitaminler gibi, eser elementler gibi.
Onlar da yeterli miktarda alınmadığı
zaman, gene ilerde damarsal yapıları
koruduğu için ilaç alınmaması da gene
olumsuzluklara neden oluyor.
Bakın mesela doğum ağırlığı
2 buçuk kilonun altında.
Ikinci planda yapılan bir çalışmada bunlar
da yüzde 15 oranında görülen kalp
hastalığı için 3 bin 200 gramın normal
yakın olduğu zaman çok daha
düşük oranda görülüyor.
Aynı şekilde hipertansiyon gene doğum
ağırlığı azaldıkça ileri dönemde daha
fazla oluyor.
Gene biliyorsunuz, daha çok kilolu
olanlarda görülen insülin direnci de gene
bu doğum ağırlığı ile ters orantılı olarak
daha fazla miktarda görülüyor.
Şimdi biz bu ya kadar geldik,
bu ilk dönemi konuştuk.
Bundan sonra bebek doğduktan sonra
altı ayı sonuna kadar.
Yani bu bin günlük yolculuğun yarısına
doğru yaklaştığımızda bebek doğduktan
sonra bu yolculukta ki en güzel hediyesi
anne sütüdür ve bu anne sütü her zaman
için kendi anne sütü değil ilk aşısı dır.
İlk altı ayda verilmesi lazım bu ideali.
2 yaşına kadar anne sütünün verilmesi,
o bin günü doldurması gerekiyor.
Önemi azaltan en önemli faktör annesiyle
beslenmesi ve beş yaş
altı ölümlerden bahsettik.
Yüzde 13'ü emzirme ile önlenebilir.
İleri yaşama da etkisi var.
Sadece o dönemde değil.
Anne sütü alan çocuk daha az hasta olur,
daha az şeker hastası olur.
Daha az yolu, daha az kanser gelişir,
daha az orta kulak iltihabı olur.
Daha zeki olur.
Bakın eğer bir gün yapılan bir çalışmada,
ciddi bir dergide yapılan çalışmada bakın
anne sütü aldıkça ne kadar fazla alıyorsa
ayıp üstü zekası daha yüksek bir spora
sahip oluyor.
Bu da beslenmeyle ilişkin olarak gene
zekayla ilgili yapılan bir çalışma.
Yani özetle ilk 1000 gündeki kötü
beslenme, kısa dönemde beyin gelişiminin
bozulmasıyla zekayı etki eden bilişsel
fonksiyonların azalmasına, yapısal
bozukluklara neden olarak vücut alma
mekanizmalarında ya da metabolik sendrom
olarak dediğimiz şeker hastalığı,
diyabet,  hipertansiyon gibi
hastalıkların daha fazla
olmasına neden oluyor.
Şimdi bu hani şimdiye kadar daha çok
beslenme ile ilişkisi konuşuluyordu.
Ama artık sonrası .
Bunun sonrası artık daha çok bizi.
Hayatımıza giren olumsuzluklar buraya da
ilk bin gün için de tehdit olmaya başladı
Bunun başında bakır cep telefonunun.
Cep telefonu için yapılan
çalışma bakıma 2017'de.
doğum oranının daha az olmasına
neden oluyor
Anne gebe iken ne kadar çok
telefon kullanıyorsa.
Cep telefonu ne yapıyor?
Cep telefonunun radyofrekans ve
elektromanyetik dalgaları var.
Bu dalgalar bebek ne kadar küçük olursa
Amerikan Pediatri Akademisi bunu
net olarak söylüyor.
İnce ve yumuşak dokularda
daha fazla geliyor.
Bakın erişkinlerde ki etkisine
5 yaşındaki isim.
Dolayısıyla mobil telefon ne yapıyor?
Her gün aslında kanser hücresi oluşuyor
ama bunlar yok ediliyor.
Bu DNA hasarları , hani cep telefonu
kullananlarda yüzde 4, kullanmayanların
yüzde 4, kullananların yüzde 40 gün
ne kadarını yok edebilecek?
Tabii bunun sonucunda ne oluyor?
kanser gelişimi daha fazla oluyor.
Bunla ilgili tabii yeni
yeni çalışmalar var.
Hani bir kısmı ilişkisi olduğunuz söyledi.
Bir kısmı ilişkisi olmadığını söylüyor ama
yayınlanan bakın mesela
beyin tümörü ile ilgili.
20 yaşından önce 4 kat.
Bu da şunu gösterir 20 yaşından
sonra iki kat olması .
Bu demin söylediğim dalgaların gelişmekte
olan beyne etkisinin daha fazla
olduğunu gösteriyor.
6 dakika üzerinde konuşursanız kulak
ve beyin dokusu artıyor.
Işitmeye bozuyor?
bak ama ABD akademisinin bildirdiği
gibi işitme kaybı oluyor.
Gözlerde katarakt oldu.
Peki çevre kirliliği?
Yine artık konuşacağımız bir diğer
durum da çeyrek gibi değil.
Çok ilginç çalışmalar yapılmış .
Özellikle Amerika'da o ayrıca yapılmış .
Orada istasyonlar var.
Bizim ülkemizde de var ve
bu partikülleri ölçüyor.
Bu partikülleri kirli olan yerlerde de
deneklere bakıyor ve bakıyorlar ki eğer,
ortamda ise yüzde 19 bir artıştan sonra
orada bebeklerin erken doğduğunu
görüyorlar ya da ölü doğum olduğunu
görüyorlar.
olduklarını görüyorlar.
Yine yeni yapılan 2020'de ki çalışmada
da batın, erken doğumu, düşük doğum
ağırlığını , ölü doğumu en az yüzde 10
oranında arttırdığı belirlenmiş .
Özetle ince partikül yoğunluğuna bakılarak
yapılan çalışmalar çok
yeni bir çalışma.
2021 diyor ki Çevre kirliliği her yıl
dünya çapında 6 milyona kadar erken,
doğumdan 3 milyon da düşük kilolu bebekten
sorumludur diye
hepimizin o da şey var.
Sorumluluğu hepimiz içerek yine
dikkat etmemiz lazım.
Sigara biliyorsunuz yani çoğumuz sigaranın
ne kadar kötü olduğunu eskiden
4 bin madde var dedik.
Şimdi 5 bin tane yabancı madde olduğu
belirlenen sigara bugün dünyadaki en
önemli riskli davranışlardan
bir tanesidir.
Ülkemizde bakın her yıl.
Her yüz yeni doğan bebekten 15'i daha anne
karnındayken sigara ile tanışıyor.
Çok ciddi bir rakam değil mi?
Bakın bu neye? neden düşüyor?
neden oluyor?
Sigaradaki nikotin dünyanın en güçlü
damar bozucu maddesidir.
Dolayısıyla damarsal beslenen bebeğin
anne karnındaki bebeğin beslenmesini
bozarak erken doğumu düşük doğum ağırlıklı
doğmasına neden oluyor.
Daha bebek anne karnındayken solunum
hareketlerini olumsuz yönde etkiliyor.
bebek, anomali bebek olarak doğma ihtimali
de daha fazla oluyor.
Sadece içen değil, ortamdaki herkes
pasif olarak da etkileniyor.
Ve aynı zamanda o, solunum yolundaki o,
silya dediğimiz, mikropları uzaklaştıran
o hareketleri, paralize ederek, bozarak
solunum yolu enfeksiyonlarına ve orta
kulak menenjit gibi enfeksiyonlar
riskini arttırıyor.
Biliyorsunuz ani bebek sendromu
varsa adını ise tek.
Bazen biliyorsunuzdur.
Bunun yüzde 25'inden sigara sorumlu.
Anne sütünü daha az almasına neden olur.
Sigara içilmesi ve astıma neden oluyor.
Aşılardan da bahsetmemek olmaz.
Aşılar da çok önemli.
Aşılandığı için 3 milyon çocuğun hayat
bulduğunu, dünyada aşılama için 2 milyon
bebeğin öldüğünü söyleyerek ve her
aşısı varolan her hastalığa karşı
aşılamanın da
bir insan hakları olduğu insan hakları
beyannamesinde de yazılıdır.
İşte bu ilk 1000 gün.
O kadar önemli ki.
Bunun için toplantılar, kongreler
düzenleniyor.
Yani özetle sağlıklı bir gebelik.
Sağlıklı bebek, sağlıklı gelecek
ve sağlıklı doğum.
Son olarak şunu söylemek isterim.
Hayatın en önemli dönemi ilk bin gündür.
İlk bin gün günde kötü beslenme ileri
yaşamı olumsuz etkilemektedir.
Cep telefonu, mobil telefon,
çevre kirliliği ve sigara.
Bunlar tehdit eden bebeği, bebeklikten
itibaren ve bütün yaşamını tehdit eden
faktörlerdir.
Yani umarım.
Bu anlattıklarım.
Daha bilinçli bir şekilde.
Çocuklara bakılır.
Çocukları uzaklaştırabiliceğimiz
Sigara gibi, cep telefonu gibi
şeylerden de uzak tutarız.
Hepinizin sağlıklı bir.....gelecek
dileyerek konuşmamı tamamlamak istiyorum.
alkış